let's go next to our caller from the
3:05 area code who's calling today from
3:05 hey David this is Brian hey Brian
hey what's going on so all I to ask how
well would you say you have gauged the
average Trump voter from 2016 outlook on
the election because was eligible in
2012 to vote for Obama around me or
whatever I was 18 at the time I didn't
vote and it really wasn't very
interested in the whole polarization of
really supporting Obama to re-elect him
we're going to Romney
yeah so I thought that when I sat out
the midterms in 2014 and then I ended up
voting for Trump in 2016 simply because
I didn't really want another Clinton in
there and he was saying all this stuff
about not wanting to get into Wars and
these things and pretty much as soon as
he bomb Syria I kind of just regretted
the whole decision and then just in
spite I just voted straight Democrat on
the midterms although I'm not a Democrat
and independent have some problems with
the Democratic Party okay but so are you
more of a progressive guy pretty much
there's a little bit of everything I
mean I come from the family that is
traditionally religious but my
grandfather supported socialist leaders
throughout his life right but is like on
Tax Policy do you think that the rich
should pay to get a tax cut is that
something you support not necessarily
well I'm asking you in practice do you
support the fact that that's what Donald
Trump did did you support that no and do
you agree with Donald Trump
strategy with North Korea for example no
I don't know
do you like the China tariffs no okay so
I mean I I just I just don't get why
you'd vote for Trump no I'm not I'm for
sure not gonna vote for dong shop again
I've already decided that like in 2017
got it armed but I don't feel like that
enthusiastic about voting democrat at
all so I may just all right Brian I'm
gonna let you go it sounds like you got
a lot going on in the background there
you know don't if you don't want to vote
I guess don't vote I would I would
encourage you to vote I think voting is
good and it's good that you're not
voting for Trump